that's me driving towards an
unauthorized outpost
deep into the west bank and when i got
to the outpost i expected the family i
was meeting with
to hit me with an earful of ideology and
a sermon on why the jews deserve to live
in this land more than the palestinians
do
instead we played music
[Music]
we ate food from their land and we
talked more about the perks of living in
the desert
close to jerusalem the best view the
best weather
close to my parents yeah excellent
it's perfect these people don't own guns
they don't lock their doors
i visited 15 settlements out here in the
west bank
to find out what motivates the people
who are at the forefront of one of the
world's most difficult and protracted
[Music]
conflicts
the west bank is home to 2.2 million
arabs
and seen by the international community
as part of a future palestinian state
but there are also more than four
hundred thousand israeli settlers living
out here which is about five percent of
israel's population
you can learn all about how they got
here in the first part of this series
many of the first jewish settlers who
checked out here in 1967
were driven by a strong ideological
mission to claim this land for israel
but things have changed quite a bit
since then
of last
the playoffs year ten minutes in a
settlement today and you sometimes feel
that you could just as easily be in a
new jersey suburb
walker's never been out the last three
days because he's got a back problem
with his wife
we're here just uh you know play a game
have a good time
clean roads big houses quality parks
good schools
close by shopping a university you ask
people why they moved out here
and instead of the original mission to
push for the israeli state
you hear things like a very good
educational system
this is a very nice country club we
wanted to have a bigger place
it's a great place to raise kids it's
just a beautiful view and it's it's our
beautiful land and i love looking at it
all the time we were looking for a
jerusalem suburb that we could afford
that was
a manageable commute close to jerusalem
extremely close to jerusalem the quality
of life
is so much better it has nothing to do
with politics having a little bit more
quiet
most people here work in the city and
you come back here at night
you come back here in the afternoon and
it's just
relaxing and quiet between the puppet
show for the kids
the bump in bar mitzvah party and 100
other examples of seemingly ordinary
suburban life
it's hard to remember that these
settlers are living at the edge of an
intense conflict
my wife and i had certain criteria one
was
we wanted to walk out of our back door
and be hiking in five minutes
of course there's still ideology here
many residents of these communities feel
connected to the settlers original
mission to resettle the hills of the
ancient judean samaria from the bible
which they call the cradle of our entire
civilization but ideological motivations
for living out here are usually
four or five items down the priority
list with quality of life reasons being
the main drivers
to tell you if my ideological reasons
was the major motivation to move over
i won't lie and that wasn't one of the
major
things that i wasn't trying to make a
statement i was trying to
find a place that would be a good place
a safe place to raise our kids
and this was the choice it wasn't at all
something that was
something that was like one of the
criteria but but it happened to be
as a real real perk of course the
hardcore back to the earth settlers
still exist
here i am with a guy who doesn't want
his name or face in my video
he lives in another outpost illegal even
to the israeli government
there's no baseball league or bagel
shops in this community
god promised to
us that this uh this is ireland
and we can we can grow here
if we listen to him this renegade
culture of taking over hilltops once
characterized the settlement movement
but now the zealous ideology that
started the movement has been deluded by
more
practical factors like house prices and
quality of schools
this real estate ad for a settlement
community i think
perfectly captures the blend of quality
of life motivations with a hint
of ideological fervor sprinkled in if
you've always felt a deep yearning for
jerusalem
now is a once in a lifetime opportunity
not only to stand within its gates
but also to build the home of your
dreams there the tranquility of a
picturesque setting and crisp mountain
air
with all the benefits and amenities that
jerusalem has to offer
ramad gibbazev is adjacent to the city
of gibaz and is connected to jerusalem
via two main highways
but make no mistake there's still a
conflict here an occupation of land that
has enormous impact on the lives of
palestinians
[Music]
[Applause]
just it sounds paradoxical but this just
seems like the safest place in the world
one of the reasons why life in many
settlements is so peaceful and pleasant
is that the government invests
proportionately more public money
into the settlement communities than it
does in mainland israeli communities
schools and the settlements receive
better funding than mainland israeli
schools in the form of better salaries
for teachers
and other educational benefits for the
kids nearly one third of all subsidized
housing in israel is in the settlements
even though only five percent of
israelis lived there
and in the past the government even ran
a mortgage subsidy program that made
living out here much
cheaper than mainland israel and things
like public transportation are cheaper
for settlers than mainland israelis
an israeli think tank found that the
government spends about 950
on each west bank resident that's more
than double what it spends on people
living in tel aviv or jerusalem
the settlement enterprise has become a
fixture of israeli institutions and
society
which helps explain why you don't need
to be an ideological activist
if you want to live out there i can't
hide the quality of life that
people are enjoying here okay i can't
hide the fact that people are moving
from the united states from very
luxurious
big homes and they choose to live in a
fraud
and they're not suffering in a front
okay they're managing to maintain a very
similar
quality of life on top of government
support lots of the gyms
theaters and parks and the settlements
are funded by foreign donors usually
americans with
ideological motivations so what you end
up with
are these attractive communities that
feel totally
ordinary and livable but that are built
on an ideological mission
and that carry heavy political
significance both domestically and
internationally even these unauthorized
outposts that are illegal under israeli
law
enjoy a good amount of support from the
government like this government-provided
soldier to protect
this illegal community or a playground
that's built by the government as well
as public waste and recycling collection
all in a place that has been deemed
illegal by the government
my house the government built it
that's the fact that's a fact these
places are connected to public water and
electricity they're totally supported in
spite of being unauthorized
and we have here everything from
internet to water to
electricity to like everywhere
but often to appease the international
community the government still tries to
appear
tough on these unauthorized settlements
back on that illegal outpost my contact
tells me that the authorities show up
about once a year to
knock down a settler's house and then
take a picture of it to show the world
that they don't tolerate illegal
settlements
but in reality they clearly do and most
of the reason
is international political reason
international forces international and
political stupid
reasons since 1967 there has been wide
government support from both right and
left-wing parties in israeli politics
which both have separate reasons for
supporting the settlers
and while the support is not the only or
even the main reason why settlements are
growing
it has surely helped turn the settler
experience into a mainstream
livable and often enjoyable situation
the original mission of the settlement
movement was to claim land deep into the
west bank preventing a palestinian state
here are the palestinian population
centers in the west bank
and here are the settlements any
proposal for giving palestinians their
own state
now has to take into account the
hundreds of thousands of israelis living
out here
no one seriously considers it possible
to remove all 400 000 residents
and while negotiations are in a
standstill israel keeps issuing permits
and settlements continue to grow these
whole peace talks are like two guys
negotiating over a pizza
while one of them is eating a pizza just
a few weeks ago the housing minister
announced that he foresees this region
down here
called guccion growing from 7 000
residents which it is currently
to a half a million in the next 10 years
israeli settlements are universally
condemned among the international
community
but no matter what you think of them
it's hard to imagine that they're going
away anytime
soon what did you think that i was
living in you thought i was living in
some sort of
tent that i was riding camels
what did you have in your imaginary
picture
the settlement movement there are half a
million people living here
in solid homes before 1996 there were
100 000 jews living over the green line
today we're approaching half a million
um
and that number is just growing jewish
people come home that's that's not
going to change
in this video i talked to a lot of
settlers whose motivations were more
practical than ideological
in the next video i'm going to go to
jerusalem and talk to the settlers who
are at the epicenter of the conflict
settlers whose motivations are certainly
much more ideological than practical
i also want to note that in this video i
talked to a lot of american settlers in
the west bank
americans make up about 15 of the
settler population
i also talked to settlers from holland
and russia
and all over the place the west bank
really is full of settlers from all over
the world